I will give thanks to the Lord with my whole heart.
I'll recount all of your wonderful deeds.
I will be glad and exulting you.
I will sing praise to your name, O Most High.
When my enemies turn back,
they stumble and perish before your presence.
For you have maintained my just cause.
You have sat on the throne, giving righteous judgment.
You have rebuked the nations.
You have made the wicked perish.
You have blotted out their name forever and ever.
The enemy came to an end in everlasting ruins.
Their cities he rooted out.
The very memory of them has perished.
But the Lord sits and thrown forever.
He has established his throne for justice.
And he judges the world with righteousness.
He judges the peoples with uprightness.
The Lord is a stronghold for the oppressed,
a stronghold in times of trouble.
And those who know your name put their trust in you.
For you, O Lord, have not forsaken those who seek you.
Sing praises to the Lord who sits and thrown in Zion.
Tell among the peoples his deeds.
For he who avenges blood is mindful of them.
He does not forget the cry of the afflicted.
Be gracious to me, O Lord,
see my affliction from those who hate me.
O you who lift me up from the gates of death,
that I may recount all your praises,
that in the gates of the daughter of Zion,
I may rejoice in your salvation.
The nations have sunk in the pit that they have made,
and the net that they hid their own foot has been caught.
The Lord has made himself known.
He has executed judgment, the wicked are snared
in the work of their own hands.
The wicked shall return to shield,
and the nations that forget God.
For the needy shall not always be forgotten,
and the hope of the poor shall not perish forever.
Arise, O Lord, let not man prevail,
let the nations be judged before you.
Put them in fear, O Lord,
let the nations know that they are but men.
This is the word of the Lord.
Let's pray together once again as we come to Psalm nine.
Lord, as I'm stood here, reminded of what we looked at
last week in Psalm eight,
that it is out of the mouths of babies and infants
that you have established strength,
because of your foes, to still the enemy and the Avenger.
Lord, your strength is made perfect in weakness.
And Lord, I pray that in our weakness this morning,
as frail people, Lord, that you would make your strength known.
Lord, I pray that you would powerfully speak to us
by your spirit as we open your word together.
Would you show us more of Jesus
and what it means to trust in Him?
With His name we pray, amen.
Amen.
Well, I'm not much of a sports guy at all.
If you've gotten to know me, you'll know that that's the case.
I kind of get lost as you talk about
whatever team you're interested in or whatever.
But there have been times when I couldn't help
but get kind of swept up in celebrations
that are happening.
Specifically, I think of when we were living
in Leicester, England, we moved there.
The year that Leicester won the premiership.
And it was like, I mean, nobody expected that to happen.
You're talking like 5,000 to one odds.
And I talk about excitement.
Like I was all of a sudden a Leicester city fan,
just like the rest of the city.
Because they brought back the trophy on this double-decker bus
and there were far more people outside their homes
in the city than inside their homes.
Hundreds of thousands, that's no exaggeration.
We're aligning the streets and like seeing that trophy
was brought in.
And then everybody then went to this local park,
Victoria Park, we all cheered on the team
as they presented their trophy,
having won this huge event.
And victory celebrations have a long history.
It goes way back before the sports
that we think of today.
I mean, even in scripture, when you look at it,
you see a number of victory celebrations
that are happening.
So you have like the crossing of the Red Sea, right?
So Pharaoh and his armies are defeated.
Moses and God's people are on the other side.
You immediately in scripture have them
this song that's being sung.
Praise in God for this victory.
You got this famous case of David and Goliath
and the Philistines being defeated.
And as the armies come back in,
women come out in the streets
and they're singing a song of victory.
So they're singing, David has killed his thousands.
Or no, Saul has killed his thousands, that was it.
But David is tens of thousands, right?
So victory followed by celebration and praise.
Then you get to the end of the Bible.
So revelation.
The city of Babylon is as fallen in Revelation 18
and God's kingdom is established.
And then Revelation 19, you then have praise
being given to God because that has happened.
So you see that pattern right the way through.
And the Psalms are full of praise
and that includes these celebrations of victory as well,
victory over God's enemies.
In fact, the theme of praise is just gonna be repetitive
over and over.
So the book of Psalms as we said already
is broken up into five different books.
And at the end of each one of those books,
no matter how hard things have been,
they all end in this kind of crescendo of praise to God.
So prayer is always leading to praise.
Well this Psalm is one of those Psalms of praise,
particularly after a victory that has been won.
But I wanna draw your attention to something specific
that is different about this
when it comes to a celebration of victory.
Because the first 12 verses praise God
as a victorious king who has triumphed over his enemies.
But then beginning in verse 13, what do we see?
You see that David is still presently under attack.
So in other words, he is praising God
in the middle of the battle,
knowing that the outcome,
the kind of victorious outcome is secure.
So yes, it's a celebration of the victory of God,
but it's a victory that is yet to see fully happen.
So you have that pattern all the way through
of victory celebration,
but here it's celebration because of future victory.
And David invites us into this praise
that he is singing here.
So verse 11, for example,
he says, sing praises to the Lord
who sits enthroned in Zion.
Tell among the people his deeds
so we can celebrate God's victory
while the battle is still raging.
This is calling us to look to God
in the face of overwhelming odds
and to praise him anyway.
In other words, when everything seems to be going wrong,
the piano's not working and whatever,
we can praise God anyway.
You would think that was a planned illustration.
So I've titled this sermon.
I don't always make a lot of titles,
but this I thought, well,
the theme really here is defiant praise.
It's like circumstances seem to be saying one thing,
but I'm gonna praise God anyway.
Now we're not gonna look at every single phrase
in Psalm nine or every single word.
There's a lot of similar themes
that we've already seen in Psalms up to this point,
but we're gonna see the gist,
the kind of main emphasis of the Psalm
and we're gonna particularly focus on this kind of aspect
of defiant praise.
So we're gonna look at kind of three things.
I mean, one we've already looked at
and that's when we praise, right?
That kind of defiant praise.
So we're not gonna spend time with that,
but the other two things I want us to see then,
so if we're gonna praise God
within this kind of defiant way,
we're gonna see how we are to praise him
and then also why we are going to praise him, all right?
So how and why is essentially what we're gonna be looking at.
So how we praise God?
Well, the first two verses,
David is repeating these I will statements.
I will, I will.
He's resolved to praise,
but not only to praise,
he's resolved to praise in the way he describes here.
So let's read it again.
He says, I will give thanks to the Lord with my whole heart.
I will recount all of your wonderful deeds.
I will be glad and exult in you.
I will sing praise to your name,
oh most high God.
So he's resolved that he's gonna praise God
in a particular way.
Now music styles have changed over the years.
Like I mostly grew up in churches
that kind of like chop the air,
you know with the old hymns,
you're standing there holding your hymn book
and that kind of thing.
And then we tried to go to that a modern church
for a little while that had a praise team
and we were singing all these modern songs
like Lord, I lift your name on high
and shine, Jesus shine.
It's interesting though,
when you look at styles of praise,
like how quick something that's kind of modern
can feel like quaint to everybody else,
even though it feels modern to you
because styles change over generations
and in different cultures,
but the substance of praise
should be the same throughout the generations
across cultures.
So the very substance of David's praise
should be the substance of our praise.
And if I had to summarize
what the substance of David's praise
or what the substance of David's praise
is characterized by,
like what would the word be?
I'd have to say integrity.
David praises God with integrity.
In other words, there is an integration
of his internal devotion
and these external expressions of praise.
So there's not a separation between those two.
Who David is on the inside
and who is coming out on the outside
in his praise.
So let's see the kind of external expressions
of praise here.
You've got thanksgiving.
Says I will give thanks.
So David here is recognizing the grace of God
and the good gifts that he has received from him
and he's offering them back up to the Lord
in his praise of thanksgiving.
So that's the appropriate response
to receiving a gift to say thank you
to express gratitude.
And certainly as the people of God now,
people who are in Christ,
we're called to as Colossians chapter two,
verse seven says,
we're called to be abounding in thanksgiving.
Another verse from Colossians,
it says, whatever you do in word or deed,
do everything in the name of the Lord Jesus,
giving thanks to God the Father through him.
So if we're receiving all of life
and all of God's good gifts in Christ,
we're then to pass that back in praise
and thanksgiving to him.
All right, so thanksgiving.
Also another external expression is recounting.
Jesus says I will recount all of your wonderful deeds.
What this is is this is remembering specific things
that the Lord has done and speaking them out.
So remembering, recounting and telling them out.
So how might we do this?
Well, when you read his word
and you see all the things that the Lord has done,
we can praise him for those things.
When you walk with the Lord through the years,
you can look back over your life
and see the ways the Lord has proven his faithfulness
time and time again.
And it does us good to recall those things,
to remember them and to tell them out to others
and to the Lord in prayer and praise.
That could mean encouragement to us,
but also fuel for our praise.
The word here recount literally means to count.
Like it's like one, two, three, four.
Let me think of George Mueller.
Do you know him?
In the 19th century, he cared for orphans specifically.
He started a number of orphanages in Bristol, England.
And he also kept a meticulous journal
and he recorded his prayers in there,
all of his prayer requests.
And it's said for people who've studied his journals
and that kind of thing that over time,
you can go back and see that there were over
50,000 specific answers to prayer.
So he would write every single day,
all these different things.
And when the Lord would answer the prayer,
he would write down the answer to the prayer right beside it.
So he could literally go back and count.
So Lord, you've done this, you've done this,
you've done this, and he's praising the Lord
for those things.
So whether or not we keep a prayer journal in that way,
we should be able to look back and say,
here's what the Lord has done,
and we praise him for that.
But you know this recounting is also part
of our witness to the world around us.
So in verse 11, we saw a moment ago
as we sing praises, he also says,
tell among the peoples his deeds.
So tell it out, not just to yourself,
and not just to one another,
but in a way that's public to the world around you.
So praising God isn't just something that we do in private,
it's how we bear witness to the glory of God
in the world.
The Lord has made us for praise,
and he's glorified in all the earth
as his people praise him among the nations.
You even see this in Acts chapter two
when the Spirit of God fills the church at Pentecost.
It says that they were telling the mighty works of God
in the things that they were saying.
So they went out speaking about God's wonderful deeds.
Just let me see here in verse one.
So there's recounting, but there's also singing.
I won't say much about this, but it's certainly here.
I will sing praise to your name.
We're commanded, sing praises to the Lord.
So praise finds expression not only in what we say,
but also in our singing.
And it's not just an optional extra for those
like you happen to be gifted in that area.
Like we're all called to sing.
You see this in Colossians as well.
I mentioned this a moment ago, but Colossians 3.16.
Let the word of Christ dwell in you richly,
teaching and admonishing one another in all wisdom,
singing psalms and hymns and spiritual songs
with thankfulness in your hearts to God.
So we were just doing that a moment ago,
singing praises to God.
And later on in the service, we do this from time to time.
We may have done it a couple of times before,
but we're gonna have a time of just to follow exactly
what we're being told to do here.
What we might call declarative praise,
where we are speaking out the promises of God's word
over one another, just kind of thinking,
okay, this is something the Lord has really spoken to me
about in his word recently.
I'm gonna read out that particular verse or whatever it is.
But also prayers of thanksgiving.
We'll have an open time where folks can just stand
and thank the Lord for what he has done.
So just to prime the pump for that,
that's coming a bit later on,
so we're gonna practice what's actually in here.
But here I want us to see this.
Praise isn't just an external expression.
It's this external expression that is springing
from an internal devotion.
So praise isn't just about our songs and our thanksgiving
and that kind of thing.
It's being submitted to the Lord on the inside
and being aware of his grace
and all that he has given to us.
So it's internal devotion.
I think we all know it's possible to sing songs on Sunday
or to say the right things when around certain people,
when your heart is actually away from the Lord,
you're not really thinking about him,
but you kind of know how to keep up the facade.
And Jesus quoted a verse in Isaiah 29
to the Pharisees and the scribes in Mark 7.
He says, this people honors me with their lips,
but their heart is far from me.
In vain do they worship me teaching commandments
or teaching us commandments, the traditions of men.
So true praise isn't performative.
Here there is no division between
what David's saying on the outside
and the state of his heart on the inside.
So interwoven with each one of these expressions of praise
is the internal condition of his heart.
So he says, I will give thanks, yes?
But let's go back to that verse, give thanks how?
With my whole heart.
So he's truly aware and deeply appreciative
of God's grace, not just kind of saying thank you.
You know, we've always kind of told the kids
to say thank you whether you like it or not.
There was one time when a lady from our,
an older lady from our church came to our house
with a present for one of our children.
And I won't tell you which one of our children it was,
but when the lady gave this gift to her,
she said, thank you, why are your teeth yellow?
So she was saying thank you, the expression was there,
but her mind was in a completely different place
focusing in on those teeth.
Anyway, back to what we were saying.
Yeah, so true Thanksgiving involves our minds and hearts,
not just our words.
Where else do we see it?
Verse two, I will be glad and exalts in you.
True praise comes from a place of delight in God.
Another way of saying that is we speak highly
of the things that we enjoy.
Like if you went to a concert,
you really enjoyed this past weekend.
Like you'd be talking about it this morning,
you know, or a game or a festival, whatever.
You get help talk about what you enjoy.
So true praise flows from hearts
that are delighting in God and rejoicing in him above all else.
You know, in exalting carries the idea of rejoicing in triumph.
Our English word exalts comes from an old Latin word,
which is leap.
That's what the word means to leap, to jump for joy.
So we're leaping in triumph.
And that leads to why we praise God.
Okay, so we've seen how do we praise God?
We praise God with integrity.
So there's that external thing that's flowing from a heart
that's after him, rejoicing in him.
And why did we praise God?
Okay, we praise God because of who he is and what he does.
So we praise God because he is worthy
because he does wondrous things.
Or we can praise God for many things.
But here in this Psalm specifically,
he's being praised as the God who is highly exalted
and triumphs over all of his enemies.
What I wanna do is just to split that into three truths
about God that we see in the Psalm.
Like he's praising this God who's exalted above all
and triumphs over his enemies.
But let's break that into three, okay?
So he's praising God first of all
because God is supreme.
Why do we praise God?
We praise him because of his supremacy.
So the end of verse two.
I will sing praise to your name.
Oh, most high.
So one of the ways that God reveals himself in scripture
is by the names that he reveals himself by.
So you have a lot of them to start with L.
So L Shaddai, God Almighty.
Well here it is L Elian, which is God the most high.
What that essentially means is that God is highly exalted.
He's exalted above all rulers and all authorities.
He reigns supreme over all things.
He is most high.
So our eyes are looking upwards to him.
And then there's a picture that's added to that.
And this picture is repeated four times
throughout the Psalm.
And that is of God being enthroned on high,
seated on high, like a king on his throne
from which he judges.
So from God's throne, he is reigning in righteousness
and executing justice.
And his reign will never end.
So you see that in verse seven.
The Lord sits enthroned forever.
He has established his throne for justice
and he judges the world with righteousness.
He judges the peoples with uprightness.
And this is put in contrast to the Lord's enemies here.
You see God being seated on the throne.
Right, so there may be times when the enemy
appears to be triumphant or those who oppose God
seem to have the upper hand against the Lord and his people.
They may appear to be powerful.
But that will come to an end.
And God himself will reign forever.
Justice is coming and the Lord will judge the world
in righteousness and he will remain
when those who oppose him have been defeated.
And he speaks of this in not only in terms
of individuals opposing him, but also like cities
and even nations opposing the Lord.
All of that will pass away, but he will remain.
I wonder if you know much about Cahaba.
You know about Cahaba?
I don't mean the Cahaba River.
The city of Cahaba, does that ring a bell?
You've never been there.
But that was the original capital city
of the state of Alabama.
And the reason you've never been there
is because the city literally does not exist anymore.
So cities come and go, including the capital city
that we've probably never even heard of,
of the state we're living in.
It's happened to far bigger cities than Cahaba.
You think of places like Pompeii or Troy or Carthage.
Like cities come and cities go.
Empires rise and empires fall.
But the Lord who is on high, seated upon his throne,
remains and rules forever.
He reigns supreme.
So how does that relate to our praise?
Well, as we look up to the Lord,
we see that he is worthy to be praised.
And he alone is worthy to be praised.
You know, it's not wrong to enjoy other things
and feel like you gotta tell somebody about how great it is.
But if you can do that and then look at the most high God
who is highly exalted over all things,
the God who's upholding all things by the word of his power.
And just not, that doesn't do anything for you.
And you're not ready to praise him.
And there's a disconnect there.
Something wrong.
If you wanna go somewhere to see how worthy this God
who's highly exalted is of our praise
and look to Jesus.
Because this God who is highly exalted,
he was highly lifted up in Jesus,
but he was lifted up on a cross.
He wore a crown of thorns.
This God who reigns over all things
was willing to lay down his life
in the place of those who opposed him.
People like us.
We praise him for his love.
It's the love of the most high.
And when you get to the end of the book, right?
The book of Revelation.
You see this is who we're praising.
We're praising the Lamb who has sacrificed for us.
The Lamb who was seated on the throne.
So Revelation 5.13 says,
to him who sits on the throne and to the Lamb
be blessing and honor and glory and might forever and ever.
So Jesus is the one who's highly exalted
and worthy to be praised.
All right, so we praise God because he is supreme,
but also secondly, because he is our stronghold.
He's our stronghold.
Let's see verse nine.
The Lord is a stronghold for the oppressed,
a stronghold in times of trouble.
The word used for stronghold here is high tower.
So it's pretty interesting.
It starts off by like, okay,
we're praising the most high God.
And now as we're looking up, praising the most high God,
he then says, and that same God who's highly exalted
is my high tower.
All right, so from up there,
like he's able to judge the world in righteousness,
but also he invites his people to come to him
and know him as our high tower, as our stronghold.
In other words, he's our source of security,
our source of protection.
You know, we went to explain this further.
We went to visit some missionary friends
in the south of France.
And they told us there's a place you gotta go.
It's the Cathar Castles.
They're in the south of France.
We went to these castles
and I started questioning our judgment
on going to these castles when we actually got there
and looked at the top of the mountain
where these castles were located.
And you have to like walk all the way up there
to finally get to these castles.
And so we went and they were amazing.
These kind of fortresses that were up there.
Well, why would somebody build a castle
on the top of a mountain?
Well, because of like,
you can see your enemies coming a mile away.
Like, and it takes them a while to get to you.
And you're at this distinct vantage point
where you can shoot your arrows down
and like attack the enemy here.
And you can read about these kind of high fortresses,
these high towers that provide security
like in scripture as well.
So people would settle for example
on high ground for added security.
People would build high towers to secure a city.
And one of the towers was even named after David.
You can read about the Tower of David.
Does anybody know where that is at?
It's Song of Solomon.
So Song of Solomon or Solomon is praising his love
saying that her neck is like the Tower of David
and is surrounded by all of these shields.
So we know there was actual tower, a high tower
because of that phrase there.
All right, so the most high God,
here's the point here,
the most high God is our source of security
in times of trouble.
So when we feel that we're under attack
or we're feeling the pressure of life,
we can go to him and know security in him
that he will look after us.
So can I just ask you, what is your stronghold?
What is your high tower that you run to?
Where do you run to for your sense of security
when the pressures of life are on?
Some people run to money
like you look at your bank balance
like or the, you know,
how the housing market is doing
and that sort of thing.
That's where you feel your sense of security
or lack thereof.
There's others who like control
or just like a sense of predictability
and like that gives that sense of security
or just, you know, comforts.
We talk about having a security blanket, right?
That there's things that comfort us,
give us a sense of security,
certain pleasures or whatever it might be for you.
Could be relationships.
Now it could be good to provide a sense of security
and stability for others.
Like I'm glad we've got security in place at church
and that sort of thing.
But on the flip side of that
it's also possible to be overly dependent on others
for that sense of security.
Or could be just looking to ourselves for that.
You know, kind of a self-reliance
where we think that the right answer
is always to just dig that little bit deeper
for the strength that we need to face
whatever it is we're going through.
There are a number of places like that.
The scripture points us to
that gives us a false sense of security
and God rebukes people who run to those other things
instead of the Lord for their security.
So in Obadiah chapter one verses three and four,
hear what the word of the Lord says there.
It says, the pride of your heart has deceived you.
You who live in the clefts of the rocks
and make your home on the heights.
You hear that?
It's kind of other places for security on the heights.
Though you soar like the eagle
and make your nest among the stars,
from there I will bring you down.
So God's saying here that he can also remove
the things that we're running to for a sense of security
that we might know him as our true refuge.
He's saying you're looking to the wrong thing.
The aim's to humble us that we might instead find refuge
in him because he's the stronghold
that lasts forever.
But the God who is supreme and our stronghold
is also thirdly, our savior.
So yeah, when David writes this,
he's praising God as his stronghold
in this time of trouble.
So he's surrounded by trouble.
He's defying that trouble and praising God in the stronghold.
But in verses 13 down to the end,
we see that David's also praying
that God would actually deliver him.
Lord, you're enough even in the time of trouble,
but I'm praying, Lord,
that you would deliver me from this trouble.
Verse 13, be gracious to me, oh Lord,
see my affliction from those who hate me.
Oh, you who lift me up from the gates of death,
that I may recount all your praises
that in the gates of the daughter of Zion,
I may rejoice in your salvation.
So yeah, so David's praying knowing
that God is his defense,
but he's also the one who brings his trouble to an end.
So throughout the Psalm, he's praising God,
yes, you read it, for his righteous judgment.
So evil is on the attack now,
but he knows justice is coming.
Judgment for his enemies will also mean
the salvation of him and his people.
Right, so he's saying, Lord,
bring their opposition to an end.
May I know your salvation and rejoice in that.
Save me, Lord.
The salvation David prays for, you see,
is praying that he'd be delivered
from the gates of death.
Verse 13.
So death is being pictured as a city,
and David has been driven right to the gates
of that city of death.
He's saying, Lord, save me from that gates,
and instead bring me into the gates of Zion.
Like bring me into your city.
You see the two gates there.
Lord, bring me away from the gates of death
into the city where you are praised.
Bring me to where you dwell among your people.
Once again, this points us to Jesus,
because many years later, he was driven
outside those very gates, the gates of Jerusalem.
And there he faced death, and he didn't just face it.
He went through the gates.
He entered into death itself,
but was raised from the dead,
and ascended to his heavenly throne
as a victorious king.
This is the savior we praise.
So he's the one who will save us from all trouble.
So Hebrews chapter nine, verse 28 says this,
that Christ, having been offered to bear the sins of many,
will appear a second time not to deal with sin,
but to save those who are eagerly waiting for him.
So we're eagerly waiting for his coming,
praying for that salvation,
praying for the trouble to be removed.
We may see those, the things that are troubling us,
removed in this life,
but it might be we have to wait until he returns,
but the savior is coming,
and he will bring trouble to an end.
He will bring salvation to all those
who take refuge in him.
So question just as we close.
What should we do until that day comes
when we know that full salvation,
the end of all our troubles?
Well, two things.
One, we pray as people in need.
Just like David in the second half of the Psalm,
we see that those who know God as their stronghold
are not people who can save themselves.
Verse nine, who is he a stronghold for?
The oppressed.
He speaks of the needy and the poor.
Verse 18, the needy shall not always be forgotten.
The hope of the poor shall not perish forever.
So who are the ones who are praising God
who know his salvation, the poor,
the needy, the oppressed?
In other words, there are people who recognize their need.
When we come to God,
we come to him with the empty hands of faith.
In just a minute, actually,
we're gonna sing, nothing in my hands I bring
simply to thy cross I cling.
We're not saying God, look at all the things
that I've done for you.
Let me into your stronghold.
Like I want to dwell in your presence because of this.
No, instead we're saying, Lord, we are poor and needy.
We have nothing but your grace.
He saves us by his grace.
And that's also true as when it comes
to how we grow in prayer.
So when we come to the Lord,
we come with the empty hands of faith.
But as we grow in the Lord,
we grow as people who are continually dependent upon him.
I heard somebody say recently,
it was in a sermon actually,
they were talking about how,
why do we really struggle to pray?
Why are we so prayerless?
And he said, I've asked people this.
It's that most people would say
it's because of a lack of self-discipline.
I don't get up early enough or that sort of thing.
That's why I don't pray.
He was kind of making the case
that it wasn't actually a lack of self-discipline.
That might be part of it,
but the issue was even deeper.
The issue is actually pride.
That's where our prayerlessness comes from
is because we live our lives
as though we can get by on our own.
While we go into the day
as though we were just autonomous people
who could just like, you know, go to work and drive it
because we live in a place of abundance as well.
And so we were not consciously needy people
who are dependent on the Lord for every breath,
for every decision that we make,
for everything that we have.
And if we were, if we humbled ourselves
beneath this highly exalted God
that we would be depending on him,
and that would then in turn fuel our praise
because if we're depending on him,
praying for him about everything,
then we see, well actually,
Lord, you answered this prayer and that prayer
and this one I'm gonna recount
all of your wonderful deeds today.
Right, so that humble dependency
leads to joyful prayer and praise.
So we pray as people of need
and then we praise him as recipients of his grace
even when things are hard.
You know, and sometimes our praise
needs to defy the appearance of our circumstances.
Could you turn with me to Hebrews chapter 13?
We're not gonna spend a lot of time here
but I just wanna read this as we close
because I've just been amazed
at the way that Hebrews 13 ties together
so many of these things
and calls us to the same kind of praise.
Verse 12 says that Jesus suffered outside the gate.
We're just talking about the gates of death
like going out.
Jesus also suffered outside the gate
in order to sanctify the people through his own blood.
Therefore, let us go to him outside the camp
and bear the reproach he endured.
For here we have no lasting city
but we seek the city that is to come.
So what are we to do?
So Jesus suffered outside the gate.
Let me say like we're gonna go,
we want to be with him
even if that means suffering with him.
So what are we then doing?
Says for through him then,
let us continually offer up a sacrifice of praise to God
that is the fruit of lips that acknowledge his name.
So even in the midst of suffering,
as we look to the one who was highly exalted
and yet suffered in our place,
we offer up our sacrifices of praise to him.
So let's pray together, shall we?
Lord, I pray that you would make us a people
of this kind of defiant praise
or because you are worthy to be praised,
not only by our lips, but by our lives.
Lord, you do wondrous deeds
and you've provided for us time and time again.
So I pray that you teach us to humbly depend upon you
to praise you for all that you provide for us.
Or we know that even in our suffering,
you reign supreme and our hope is found in you.
Lord, I pray that you would open our hearts
and our mouths that we might sing your praise.
In Jesus' name, amen.